bei mir ist jetzt peter hütter ihn kurz
ein islamischer mystik und schlechtes
bbb orten sie in der schweiz herr kunz
haben wir in rauschzuständen zugang zu
einer anderen art von realität
vielleicht sogar zu etwas göttliches
absolut würdig war verstehe ich das 1 1
eine situation wo ich einfach wegwerfen
hier
ich will wo anders sein ich hab das was
ich hier erlebe und in das genügt mir
nicht ich muss ab und zu mal weg von da
und das machen wir ganz gezielt ab und
zu mal weg von da also mit den räten
sind die wir organisieren und die wir
selbst pflegen ist dass einmal ein
aktuell momentanes weg von hier genau
und diese drei tänze bis jetzt erwähnt
haben die schauen wir uns kurz an sie
sind sie haben früh zum islam gefunden
muss man sagen
1967 sind seit 20 jahren schon so was
wie ein abt oder ein lehrbeauftragter in
diesem metier wie orten der geht zurück
auf einen islamischen mystiker
dreizehnter jahrhundert rooney heißt er
und wie diese drehten sie ausschauen das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal gemeinsam an
[Musik]
das ganze findet statt hier in einer
kirche in zürich und man sieht schon es
ist ein ritual traditionelle gewänder
man sieht hier sie im bild mit diesem
speziellen hut sie leiten diese
zeremonie
[Musik]
was ist denn das zu dieser treten sie wo
wir mal hin
also wir wir orientieren unsere
monotheismus das ist der judentum
christentum und islam und tourismus ist
teil des islams und das ist
monotheistische orientierung ist habe
ich mal die orientierung
ich vergleiche sie sich deswegen ich
mich nicht mit buddhisten und anderen
orientierungsmöglichkeiten und und wir
sagen dass die st das ist dieser zustand
wo warum und zeit herrschen wo wir
gefangene von raum und zeit sind und da
wir schütten sie uns immer nur halb weil
wir wissen oder fühlen dass es noch eine
andere welt gibt das traditionell
jenseits genannt wird
ich nenne es gern das hintergründige das
heißt bei allem was wir sehen erkennen
in dieser welt auch mit forschung und
allem werden wir die augen haben zu
sehen dann sehen wir weiter noch etwas
hintergründiges und in dieser drehung
erlebt man einen zugang zu diesem
hintergründigen zu diesem gegenseitigen
ja es ist eigentlich ein weg zum
esoterischen herz nach unserem modell
oder nach hinten zu vorstellt auf uns
orientierung ist diese satirische herz
der punkt wo es zu jenseitigen drüber
geht
das kann sich ein meditativer prozess in
diese mitte und wenn ich dort bin dann
öffnet sich die tür des kunden welt was
man kommt in die eigene mitte
aber verliert irgendwie auch das eigene
ich in diesem zustand also der jahres
ist das ist das ziel ist eigentlich dass
ich von meinem ich wegkomme
der normale mensch ich gehöre auch ein
halber mensch natürlich haben die sogar
an normale menschen die wollen
selbstbewusstsein ja ich stärken
da stehen vor allem wir alle wollen
jemand sein
und wenn wir uns beobachten beobachten
für uns doch wie stark machen wir alle
unsere handlungen davon abhängig dass
wir irgend einer art anerkennung
bekommen und sichtbarkeit bekommen
wir wollen uns stärker und die ganze
mystik ist seit ich eine umkehrung sage
ich muss von diesem ich heftigkeit
wegkommen
ich muss nicht mehr jemand sein wollen
um ist extrem zu sein
wer meister eckhart dieser christ ich
müsste er sprach vom endt werden zb so
ein konstrukt eines ein wie ein ein wort
ein deutsches wort and werden also
dieser prozess vom weg kommen von diesem
ich hafte das klingt für mich als laie
aber auch nahe beim buddhismus dass das
ego dass ich eine fiktion ist und dass
man das in diesen mystischen erfahrungen
auch erkennt erlebt das ist ganz nahe
beim buddhismus ich habe ich komme sehr
gut zurecht methodisten nach nachdem
gemeinsame sache
es ist einfach so dass wir das diesseits
ebenso gleichwertig bewerten wie das
jenseits
das sähen sich nicht besser als das
diesseits also es ist einfach wie sie
nur halt wenn wir nur das diesseits
erkennen und im diesseits leben wollen
wenn wir unsere
wir uns um sowohl nur an uns wohl denken
die feste laufzeit gebunden und das
jenseits ist nicht etwa einfach nur das
schöne es ist nicht nur dass du die
jenseits des jenseits hat nicht nur er
sondern auch teufel also jenseits ist
einfach die andere seite der münze wir
sagen gott hält diese münze in der hand
das erst noch größerer seine schöpfung
und die abgründige dunkle seite erfährt
man auch wenn man in diesem mystischen
bewusstseins zuständen ist ja das kann
man ja sowieso ja das kann man sehr wohl
und die aufgabe einer religion oder
mystische tradition ist ja gerade dass
wir wie ordnet und geschützt diese
grenzübergänge hinkriegen und in
gemeinschaft auch gemeinschaft ist ein
schutz
das ist schon ein schutz an sich als die
gemeinschaft ist ein mittel um geschützt
zu sein
die zugehörigkeit in einer schützenden
geschützten rahmen
es geht darum dass ich loslassen kann
wer kann loslassen ohne geschützt zu
sein
ohne die gewissheit zu haben ich komme
nicht ab sie gehört wie soll nach hause
und so weiter da wenn wir die
kontrollmechanismen oder wir verlassen
uns auf etwas das mich trägt die
gemeinschaft soll mich tragen dass ich
voll los was ich schon interessant und
es ist auch sehr stark reguliert dieses
dieses ritual wenn man sich die tänzerin
es vorstellbar dass das pure gegenteil
hier wird sozusagen genau geregelt
gedreht wie eine art von meditation die
auch sehr stark geregnet ist bei der
vorbereitung habe ich zwei dinge
fasziniert nämlich das ich gelesen habe
dass diese dieses drehmoment dieses sich
drehen
eigentlich gar kein rausch ist sondern
ist ein einklinken ja eine bewegung die
im ganzen universum da ist vom kleinsten
atom bis zu den galaxien
ja das ist dadurch die eine der symbol
des die symbolik dieses rituals rituale
war ist nicht plötzlich bei ihr
gestohlen worden
das ist entwickelt hat sich entwickelt 2
300 jahre
norden zu dem was es jetzt ist da ist
symbolik ihn eingeschlossen und die
ganze technik die ganze die kleid das
ist alles nicht etwas das zurzeit von
ruby schon war
zurzeit und romy war spontanes drehen
und er hat das quasi was man schon
kannte dieses drehen hat das salonfähig
gemacht
in seinen kraft seiner bekanntheit und
seiner stärke und sein rad und sie haben
wir im vorgespräch gesagt wenn man da so
dreht und das geübt hat darin ein
meister ist dann machen die erfahrung
dass man selbst plötzlich stillsteht und
die welt dreht sich nicht mehrmals das
ist dann hat sich die erfahrung wenn
jemand das wirklich gut kann da gibt es
so momente wo ich kann nicht mehr merke
ich hab das schon von nach von evelyne
binsack abi solche aussagen gehört ich
merke gar nicht mehr wie ein angestrengt
ich bin die spitze wie ich krieche ich
fühle mich völlig in ruhe in und um mich
hast die welt herum und ich bin selbst
sind ruhig das sind so momente sehr oft
ist das so zwischendurch nicht ganz denn
unser weg ist die kein das gibt es nicht
ein warum ich hab's geschafft dass
disney unsere welt ist ein unendlicher
weg und die auf wie sie dem auf dem weg
also ist die mine annähern denn wenn wir
ganz drin sind schlussendlich dann
verbrennen wie er sagt man die jungs
also es ist diese bekannte bild der des
nachfolgers der um die kerze flattert
weil er vom licht angezogen ist man
trinkt dann ist er verbrannt das wäre
der tod aber bei ihnen ist es sozusagen
ein wie ein versuchsweise ein tor das
ich loszulassen
ein stärken bevor man wirklich stehen
also ist die alte mystic auch angelis
silesius der christliche musik hat das
gesagt wer nicht stirbt bevor er stirbt
vor die ablehner stirbt
sehr schön sie waren ja das leben lang
eigentlich ein suchender und bevor sie
auf den religiösen weg gekommen sind
sind sie mit langen haaren in den 60er
jahren und barfuß drei jahre lang um
gelaufen waren eine richtige hippie und
haben den rausch so gesucht haben
auch drogen genommen was war das für
eine erfahrung
das war rückblickend ist vor allem eine
liste erfahrung also ich habe nur ich
habe nicht stark aber ich habe es ab und
zu ich war pia liste gekommen mit
freunden und was mir da auch noch heute
als lehrreiche erinnerung ist ist eben
dass die abendevent nicht nur gut ist
otto bock schwarzes hat licht und
schwarze seiten im jenseits also ich
habe aus meiner erfahrung öffnen sich
die tore zum jenseits mit den mit sachen
drogen und wenn ich nicht vorbereitet
bin nicht wirklich kommt einfach das
auch nicht so was irgendwie mehr platz
findet ich habe da wirklich ein freund
gehabt der hat immer schlechte oder fast
lieber schlechte trips gehabt ist so
leiter dann auch in der psyche gelandet
und ich habe immer nur gute gehabt
runden das wir waren freunde wir haben
zusammen dinge gemacht
er lebte und ich erlebe sanders und sie
würden sagen dass verstärkt etwas was
schon in mir drin ist ja was ich mir war
schon ich behaupte dass jetzt war schon
etwas das standhaft war dass ich habe
die kontrolle gehört von unserer
philosophie hier ist es ist für mich ja
immer wichtig gewesen ich bin nahezu
dollar mensch und und die liebe zur
schönheit der quandts viel herzlichen
dank für dieses gespräch
danke
[Applaus]